[Music]
hello YouTube chess Louis in my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the 29th
episode of my chest trap series this is
a special episode guys as I'm so excited
to reveal one of my own invented trap
against London system from black
perspective there are two great things
about this trap number one if we check
the online database there is not a
single feed a game played with this line
yup you heard it right
not a single game so that means you can
literally use this as a great surprise
weapon in the tournament practice number
two let's say even though your opponent
doesn't fall for the trap guess what you
still get a decent and attacking
position on white King side with all the
winning chances now just before we start
I like to thank leet defense team of
leeches for showing me the idea and the
pattern to create this wonderful trap
the London opening arises after the
following model D for D 6 and here y can
start either with the move Bishop to f4
consider as accelerated London system or
the traditional move Knight to f3 which
leads to the normal London system well
apart from this if your opponent
contains with E 4 or c4 then I'm going
to recommend you play the move c6 Queen
c7 and if you remember I have created a
whole video on this line namely
Universal chess opening against d4 so if
you haven't check it out I insist you to
check that video which give you a very
good recruiter against the move d4 ok
let's start with a normal London system
starting with Knight
three afterwards you can choose either
the move c6 or Bishop to g4 in this game
black choose c6 our universal chess
opening model and after Bishop to a full
black continue with Bishop to g4 so you
can see the big idea is if black wants
he can capture the knight on f3 double
the white pawn which in many end games
considered to be a great advantageous
for the black side so accordingly what
is not going to allow this so the move
frequently happened here is III so in
case black capture the knight then what
will recapture with the Queen and that
way white pawn structure will remain
intact well so far why doesn't have any
problem to play his London system moves
and hoping for a solid structure with
equal middle game but not many London
player are ready to face this move this
is the point where GG trap against
London system comes into the picture
where at first sight this looks like
completely stupid right because what's
the point of sacrificing this pawn and
can't white just easily grab this pawn
well yep he can do that except the game
is finished right there as white has
straightaway fallen into GJ chess trap
territory after this move black is
instantly winning and I hope you did see
this continuation Bishop captures f3
removing the defender of the g5 Bashar
and after Queen captures f3 and quayne -
if I check just within 6th move of the
game black emerge with an extra piece
and in fact a
completely winning position well so far
in many blitz games I have found many
many victims in this line and you won't
believe there are some title players
fallen for this so this is a great way
to surprise your opponent and get the
win very very quickly well some of you
says it's not compulsory that white is
going to capture on GFI what happens if
white bishop goes to the g3 well this is
exactly what I was talking about in the
starting of the video here black
planning of campaign is very simple he
will continue with Knight to f6
and if h3 then Bishop garage fire is a
very strong reply and I have attached a
sample line in the PGN which gives black
a good attacking position on the Kings
side so accordingly in one game my 2188
opponent continued it Knight B to d2 and
I think this game is a model
demonstration how good black position is
getting on the Kings side once he can
able to complete his piece development
okay night b d2 is a good move because
not only protecting f3 but stopping
Knight to e4 idea of a black but I'm
afraid it is not going to stop what
actually black wants to do namely Knight
to h5 so black planning is very simple
he wants to capture the bishop and after
the game continuation that is Bishop to
c4 e6 so blunting the diagonal of the
bishop Queen to e2 so white is remaining
very flexible and he can go either side
castling but on the other hand black has
more moves as I simply continue with
Knight to d7 of a typical idea of the
universal chess opening Queen to c7 and
in all this lines what you have to
black is generally going to castle on
the kingside with a very good attack on
the White King side so the game
continues with castling on the Queen
side I played Knight captures g3 and
after pawn captures g3 I decided to take
the initiative immediately with defy
attacking the bishop Bishop to d3 and
now the star mo of the game fi
restricting white to play Evo and look
at that pin which is so deadly and it
will take a whole lot of time for white
to remove those major pieces from the
diagonals well he did in the game he
played Quinto even I continued with
Quint web six planning to castle on the
Queen side and still that pin is so
annoying so I take another step to move
the rook with King to be one but these
moves are very time-consuming which
gives black all the time in the world to
complete his piece development such as
castle on the Queen side and after rook
to c1 finally White Knight is unpin but
black will say thank you so much as
after Bishop to d6 black rooks are
connected and once this happened you
will see the dangerous blow on the White
King side as game finished very quickly
with Knight to h2 attacking the bishop
bishop to h5 no way black is going to
give up the bishop pair and after f3
Bishop to g6 and g4 black delivered this
decisive blow h5 and I'm afraid Whitey's
completely busted on the Kings side at
this point my opponent was low on time
and by mistake he made this blunder G
captures h5 which gives me the instant
winning move rook captures h5 and to his
horror my opponent realized that
he is about to lose as tonight and in
fact the game instead of G captures as
far if white has continued with G
captures fi then even after he captures
fi you can easily see black has
tremendous space on the kingside and
slowly but gradually those pawns are
going to move forward and create some
problems on the white cam and if you
check this position for the engine it is
giving black a good advantage so that's
the way you should play if your opponent
doesn't fall for the trap well the same
trapping business can be applied if you
open an off for the accelerated London
system water that is Bishop to f4 and
after c6 if here white continue it night
we have three then obviously we are
going to play Bishop to g4 and
transposing the line which we have seen
earlier but proper accelerated London
water is III afterwards
can you guess blacks next reply yup it's
very obvious g5 and if your opponent is
foolish enough to capture this pawn then
after Queen - if I check that poor
Bishop is a corner so that's not a good
possibility by white and instead of that
if white continue with Bishop to g3 then
once again black get this superior King
side attack
starting with Queen to b6 attacking on
b2 it doesn't matter whether your
opponent continue with b3 or Quincy one
let's say in one game against a title
player my opponent continued quintus
even but then black and simply reply
with c5 and after c3 Knight to f6 trying
to go for the bishop pair white reply
with Knight to d2
here you can play Knight to h5 but I
offer the more a grocery approach namely
Bishop to a5 if Knight to c4 then Queen
to c6 is a very strong reply so in the
game
white continue with his usual London
setup starting with Knight to f3
attacking on GI and this time around
that is another move which you should
always look out which in fact I have
played in this game namely rook to g8 so
idea is very simple we want to play h5
and then at the right moment we can
crash through on the White King side my
opponent responded with Bishop to e2 so
somehow he wants to complete his piece
development but I'm afraid this is a
very crammed position by white as black
simply continue with Knight B to d7 and
after castle on the Kings side you can
easily guest black next move yup
it's a thematic h5 so if allowed then h4
and nab the piece here white cannot play
as three as g4 is a very strong reply so
in the game I think my opponent find the
only resource h4 but I guess this is
just asking for aid as after pawn takes
Bishop takes not only this open up the G
file for the rook but after Bishop to at
six black has an option either to castle
on the coincide or in some lines he can
keep his King safe on the f8 and
concentrate on the King side attack all
in all I would say this positions are
fun to play as a black and it is who
Levite who is surviving for not to lose
the full point
well that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn my wonderful invention against
London system you definitely want to try
out in one of your own game and let's
say even white doesn't capture on g5 and
play the move Bishop to g3 in most of
the cases black get a tremendous
attacking position on the kingside which
we all want to play against boring dull
London system player thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment on this and I'll
meet you in my next episode we're very
soon bye and take care